[Music]  hi I'm Danny ran in a way a long time  let's go here I'm Danny Rand welcome I  left here 10 years old and a jet to my  parents i became the lone survivor Danny  ran back from the dead  why didn't waited this long to show up  how the hell did he learn martial arts  wedgied rain come on  my father instilled in me a love and  respect for this company that has never  failed this is my home  brand is my company this city is no  place for daddy we will give it up no  pyramid will many what happen to you why  are you really back here some bad people  got on the inside criminals I know what  they are but they can do despite them we  need someone with special skills I've  been training my whole life  I'm with you so you're not you need me  the change is coming down become with  you were meant to be  I am the iron fence how does that mean  you